>> Okay.
Uh, I think the issue of povertyis absolutely
crucial.
Unless you address global poverty then many
of the other issues that
people want to talk about don't get aaddressed
at all.
Umm, I am President of the Homeless World
Cup.
We, uh, involve homeless people from many,
many countries, nearly 60
countries in the world, in playing football
and then use that as a way
of, uh, taking them away from on the streets
and being homeless and
we've found that to be quite success.
Now, I think what we need to do is build on
the microproducts -- uh,
projects such as the Homeless World Cup and
they get help with, uh,
the private sector, and government sector,
and try and create
something which is, uh, global in its, uh,
appeal and global in its
solutions.
Umm, I'm here at the world economic forum
and I think there is
generally a broad feeling amongst everybody
in all sectors that, uh,
something has to be done about poverty globally
but, umm, you know,
it's a question -- everybody's agreed poverty
shouldn't exist and
homeless shouldn't exist, how do we actually,
uh, proceed, uh, tackle
from?
So what we try and do, therefore, I think
is important is to explain
things -- little projects like the Homeless
World Cup -- although it
is very, very effective is actually tiny in
the landscape -- is to try
and connect up all the little tiny projects,
learn from each other,
partner from each other, and then take the
whole thing to scale and
defea t poverty.
You know, I'm a big believer in a hand up
rather than a handout and so
it's that type of, umm, philosophy that has
to run through any
solution.
People living in the poverty kind of have
a solution at of their hands
and what we have got to do is create [unintelligible]
and just
[unintelligible].